[Musik]
das ist ja gesetzlich zu mit hoher
zeiten als offen
das ist zwar nicht die ist dass das
tragen ist die resonanz seiner musik vor
was zu mancher handelsschiff jetzt hat
das kräftig hat das auch und gerade sehr
können ersteigert das ganze so mancher
handelsschiff karte auswählen und den
hans mahr aber die ganze kisten und
alles hand und winke
das macht sagte jung das ist aber
effektive sklavenhandel das russische
dass kräfte sind unheimlich schöne alte
schiffscrew nervös gemacht haben früher
mit den tresor schwere große drinks
tresor
das haben nicht da kann es aus als
poster und nach majak romako nach unten
als booster und und sagen was das ganze
gemüse aus sowohl was das symbol sondern
ich habe die aareal erzählen als als
schiff sicher archiv kulturnetz shift
grund einer motorrad einfach alles
draußen das ist halt dazu unterwegs weil
die liab runde nachdem der 57 jährige
zürcher christian drescher hatte einen
großen traum
ein event lokal mit wellnessbereich hier
auf der geraden ronald doch dann kam das
große feuer und sorgte für ein böses
erwachen
und genau davon handelt unser film
[Applaus]
der neunte november 2009 10 samstag früh
der fast 90-jährige berggasthof
fronalpstock steht in flammen
verletzt wird niemand ein großes glück
denn besitzer christian drescher wohnt
seit rund einem jahr im haus in dieser
nacht ist er aber in zürich
auch der helikopter kommt beim löschen
zum einsatz
dennoch gibt es einen totalschaden
unten im ort wallace wohnen die
ehemaligen besitzer des bag gasthofs
fronalpstock das ehepaar frenzel brunner
reich 30 jahre hatten sie das stockhus
wie man es hier nennt betrieben grenze
war dem service bruno in der küche jede
zwei kinder sind im stock hohes auf 1300
meter über meer groß geworden
schöne jahre sagen sie aber der kam von
die kunden wurde in letzter zeit immer
härter schließlich entschieden sie sich
auch altersbedingt zu verkaufen
für knapp 800000 franken an christian
träsch der brand ihres ehemaligen hauses
ein schock
und dann
stock untergebracht was ja im vollbrand
und sie müsse
starcraft ii modell sieg und dann hat es
natürlich dass gott und nachdem ein
stimmungs vorgesehen der benötigte
stockhofe dieser rauchsäule gesehen und
auch das stimmt dann hat der gastank
regionales
david pries ja das einfach so dass ich
ein für bauern sehen diesen stil oder
ich habe auch durch gar nicht groß
studiert und so
jetzt aber weiß man dass er so erzählt
und das plötzlich bei aller
betroffenheit im glarnerland wird auch
gemunkelt brandstiftung
die rede ist von farm sanieren das
stinkt doch zum himmel schreibt jemand
reiseland ist kommentiert und russland
versuchen einfach vor gericht oder wer
will kann dann hast du stankus hat sind
und es hat und wer hat dir das vor mehr
als zwei jahren gebaut wie in einem
formtief tmx die heimat und mittags
besser du weißt du was und dass ich von
borussia co er hat dass er genau damit
über und ja und ich werde zwar kleiner
geworden und das ausgesprochen
[Musik]
zwei tage nach dem brand fahre ich mit
christian drescher in richtung
fronalpstock erst langsam werte neben
der verlust bewusst
funktioniert
also ich drücke dir flügel darauf sind
dass ein emotionsloser die wieder zurück
das ganze historische gefühlsmäßige und
auch der bund das jetzt anders lebt
die ewigkeit
herzig und das ist höchst
nicht einfach
[Musik]
wunderbar
übrigens treffen mit fast allen gleich
per du auch mit mir
ein brandort ist die polizei auf
spurensuche
[Musik]
dies war auch sie
städtischen kitas ich dieses buch
einfach weg und in denen eigentlich
hätten überall verkoppeln und dann hätte
man euch drauf und alles das ganze wird
von der bayerischen tanken wenn ich das
explizit überall gesteckt hat
[Musik]
beweise nach einem brand zu finden so
etwas vom schwierigsten sagt man uns und
wenn der betroffene hausherr selber vor
ort ist wird die polizeiarbeit noch
delikater die schöne stadt und wir sind
alle sehr dass der rektor
ich habe startet ruf muss halt ruft oder
nein ich habe das ein bisschen außen
braun tut also gut und der hans die neue
deckel draufgemacht ihnen spitze der
gegossen oder das ist das modul kann
das ist vom also was hat es mit dem
profitieren auf sich mit einem video
heraus quasi habe ich gehabt ja aber ich
muss den kopf rein ästhetisches damit
mich sicher sehr zerbrachen
also muss ich irgendwie schützen was man
sowieso nicht ganz passt dass wir da mit
dem wort mitbieten dem sie nicht einfach
mit dem mitmieter schuf an der druck es
gibt immer sachen natürlich träumen aber
nicht was ich mir dass man kontakt mit
der frau dann haben wir sie nach ihren
frage was wünschen sie ist sehr
emotional
aber ich sehe also verschläge zu
erzielen nach ein wenig länger mit
bewies sie ihre jobs oder durchaus okay
aber sie ist natürlich münster stars
lagen 2 einfach was auch drin sind wo
man nicht einfach rot und wechsele ich
schließe das ist so unsere bedürfnisse
klosterfrau das problem sie will ruhig
trauen gegen den verdacht der
brandstiftung wird sich drescher
vehement das mache überhaupt keinen sinn
so kurz vor ende der bauarbeiten
0 kommentare so alt wie die so schaffen
warum soll ich das als sünde die ja wo
die er wohl die ua copan das sind genau
die die kommune so vorstellen da die
nichtsnutzige tage nichts sie den
ehrgeiz die sich an der oder und fragen
stellen und sagen okay warum
das seebad utoquai in zürich jede
betreibt drescher seit 1997 eine sauna
mit medizinische massage wellness darum
komisch im super g zu wählen ist und
büchenberg
ich danke schön
schöne idee
nach dem brand des stockes hat er hier
fürs erste eine bleibe die jene was ich
für die jenen also nicht dass gar nichts
mehr
ich hoffe sie haben die ganz wichtig ist
auch alles da bin ich leider dobberkau
und der vergangenheit aus das ist mir
wichtig ist
und das macht also libyschen massen das
macht schnitt
ich bin sporttherapeut oder auch wir
haben ganz gut angestellt die letzte
hier geschlafen aber wurde von und zwei
rumänen und also lieder von massage das
marina bay und wc und dann haben wir das
es ist traumhaft
traumhaft krise techniker rühmlich mit
körperlich angeschlagen
buch nicht mein buch nämlich
tagsüber geht es erneut in richtung
klares wo er vor 15 jahren ein
zusätzliches mädchen entdeckte
berufsfischer
von golfern aus
ein golfer
im finish bekannt wurde dass der
berufsfischer vw saniert wird und dann
habe ich mir dank dann könnte ich hier
anstatt auf familie heimischer fisch
dann habe ich mich beworben hat das
potente boas einziger focus
der bis zumindest einmal als ziel haben
wir alles aber als die mussten gut
vorstellen recht untypisch und blieb
eine unterländer du bist ein zirkus in
glaubens aber nicht mehr
ich bin wieder auf dem thron als fünf
tage nach dem brand es ist viel los
heute versicherungsexperten
kantonsvertreter und anwälte sind auf
platz ein wichtiger tag
wer wird wie viel bezahlen müssen wenn
überhaupt kamera und mikrofon sind bei
der begehung nicht erwünscht
auch die ehemaligen besitzer frenzel
polo reich sind vor ort um christian zu
unterstützen sagen sie er sei halt
manchmal etwas gar emotional
[Musik]
mit fränzi fahrig anschließend wieder
ins tal sagt was sache ist alles
und was alles kaputt ist und was mag
sich wohl dass der brandausbruch für
michael becker wie das ganze
der brand war auch gegangen ist und
dachte das ist ein mittel nun ist sie
also wer jetzt die nächste woche weiter
zweiter geworden
und wer den anspruch an den extra hätte
meine aufrichtige kommen
knapp vier wochen nach dem großen feuer
anfangs dezember 2009 10
die glarner polizei hat sich gemeldet
der brandplatz stockhus sei freigegeben
fränzi wohnung christian wollen schauen
was wir noch zu retten ist
[Musik]
der schock war dass das ist
grundrichtung vom wasser lagert sich da
ist alles privat drin alles private
stadtring sie auch bezüglich der
möglichen brandursache ist man
offensichtlich weiter gekommen
patrick entlastet brown muss auch ist es
brauch ist
wie heißt unbekannt technische bekommt
der technische defekt ist ganz okay das
ist es wir sind jetzt der turbolader am
hut sie gestern die social frage wo der
polizei der bande lag macht
die informationen betreffend der
unbekannten technischen ursache habe er
von der polizei erhalten allerdings bei
der staatsanwaltschaft claros ist die
strafuntersuchung bis heute pendent
es ist die ganz ohne nachgesagt dafür
schlug jetzt für das schießen mit lauch
eine vokal gespielt hat kann ich was das
bedeutet sie sind klobig
[Musik]
nein das glaubst du in diesen trümmern
liegt aber noch weit wertvolleres mit
dem ein halbes jahr liegt der brand
zurück
der hausrat habe die versicherungen
christian drescher bereits entschädigt
und auch der gebäudeversicherer
anerkennt dass ihm geld für den neubau
zu stehen rund 1,4 millionen franken
vielleicht noch mehr
die verhandlungen laufen derweil freut
sich tranche über alles was ihr in asche
und ruinen noch findet der herr mach das
mal aus dem ganz großen traum haben 50
zeilen hass das symbol ist ja nicht nur
symbolisch lange nicht kriegst du
die braut hat david team blieben mit dem
abbruch der ruinen will er mitte juni
beginnen nächstes jahr im herbst also
ist zu tun
es ist es fertig verursacher und dadurch
im herbst und winter 21 ihnen die
richtig machen und fröhlich 220 schiffe
erste pläne für den wiederaufbau gibt es
bereits durch ein stück im detail zeigen
die für diese derzeit nicht
die bewilligung steht noch aus aber es
soll eine tolle sache werden
kurzfristig hat es so oder so andere
prioritäten
die wertsachen unter den trümmern
so sind die verdammten diamanten musik
studieren
ja die gibt es so zu ende finde
wieso hast du diamante was sagst du coq
arena familie traumhaft schönes stück
mit volker stein das was du so um
einander gut ließen sind hat sofort
wieder europa schicht und schnäbel
[Musik]
dazu trugen mützen spaß machen